dos automóviles se acercan a una
intersección desde direcciones
perpendiculares la velocidad del primer
automóvil es de 50 kilómetros por hora y
la del segundo es de 90 kilómetros por
hora en cierto instante de subíndice 0
el primer automóvil está a una distancia
x dt subíndice 0 de 0.5 kilómetros de la
intersección mientras que el segundo
está a una distancia bien
dt subíndice 0 de 1.2 kilómetros de ella
cuál es la tasa de cambio de la
distancia de dtm entre los automóviles
en ese instante y después dice cuál es
la ecuación que resuelve el problema y
observan nos dan cuatro ecuaciones por
aquí así que puedes pausar el vídeo e
intentar ver si llegas a la respuesta
correcta pero de cualquier manera vamos
a trabajarlo juntos así que hagamos un
esbozo de lo que está pasando esto
siempre nos ayudará a resolver el
problema
dos automóviles se acercan a una
intersección desde direcciones
perpendiculares ok imagina que por aquí
tengo a uno de los automóviles voy a
hacer por acá las llantas por aquí tengo
a mi automóvil ok es este y va en
dirección x hacia un punto de
intersección que supongamos que es este
y porque tengo a otro automóvil déjame
poner que va en esta dirección va en
dirección james y si hago el dibujo me
quedaría algo más o menos así este es mi
segundo auto bien y nos dicen que en
cierto instante de subíndice cero el
primer automóvil está a una distancia x
dt subíndice 0 de 0.5 kilómetros de la
intersección ok si llamamos a esta
distancia x
dt m
ok y llamamos a esta otra distancia
y de tema déjame ponerlo
dt entonces cómo es que la distancia
entre los automóviles está relacionada
con x dtm y con jet dt bueno me observan
se trata de aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras entonces tenemos que la
distancia entre estos dos automóviles
serán la hipotenusa de este triángulo
rectángulo recuerda están viajando en
direcciones perpendiculares entonces
aquí tengo un triángulo rectángulo
por lo tanto usando el teorema de
pitágoras esta distancia va a ser igual
a x el dt
esto elevado al cuadrado más 7 t esto
también elevado al cuadrado y tomar la
raíz cuadrada de eso esto será de dt o
dicho de otra manera de dt elevado al
cuadrado es igual a equis de tema eso
elevado al cuadrado más 7 también
elevado al cuadrado y esta es la
relación entre 77 y ddt y esta relación
es muy útil porque podemos tomar la
derivada de ambos lados de esta ecuación
con respecto a t y al hacerlo usaremos
la regla de la cadena y otras reglas
para obtener esta derivada y esto nos
dará la relación entre la tasa de cambio
de la distancia de dt entre esta tasa de
cambio que será de prima de t y las
tasas de cambio entre el x7 como también
x dt y jeter por sí mismos
ahora si vemos estas opciones podemos
ver que el inciso d nos da exactamente
la ecuación que pusimos acá lado tenemos
la misma relación a la que llegamos la
cual nos dice que la distancia entre los
automóviles al cuadrado es igual a la
distancia x hasta el punto de
intersección del primer automóvil al
cuadrado más la distancia james hasta el
punto de intersección del segundo
automóvil al cuadrado y podemos tomar la
derivada de ambos lados para resolver la
pregunta sobre cómo se relacionan las
tasas de cambio en fin ya tenemos la
respuesta y por lo tanto nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo